- Did you also work on any new music?
I know a lot of artists,
like during the pandemic worked on.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Like, I'm excited
for you to have new stuff.
- You know, thank you so much.
- Yeah.
- It was a weird, you know,
situation at first,
kind of trying to like,
I know a lot of friends of mine
who are artists struggled with like,
some of them were more inspired than ever
and felt themselves like in one space,
being able to create.
And others who didn't
necessarily feel that way.
And I
found myself in that
sort of space of like,
this is, I finally feel
like I have the time
to get this right.
And to tell this story
the way I want to sonically, lyrically.
And I'm very excited about this music
that I've been working on.
It's all the projects almost.
It's almost done.
(audience cheers)
I'm always so nervous to
say anything about my music
'cause then they're like,
oh it's coming, it means
it's coming tomorrow.
- [Kelly] I know, but
that's so cool though,
'cause people are excited.
You have some great music.
- [Hailee] Thank you.
- So people are stoked about it.
I've always wanted to,
I mean, just personally,
I want to hear a singer-songwriter album
from you, like really hardcore.
- [Hailee] Oh my god.
(audience cheers) Thank you.
- [Kelly] 'Cause you're an actor,
so you'd do a really
good job of storytelling.
- Thank you.
- Like even when it's got like a beat,
like I love your voice.
I love those songs, but I,
at one point in your life,
please, for me, you just do that.
- [Hailee] You got it.
If you'll be on it with me.
- Fine. Fine. I'll do backgrounds.
I love singing backgrounds.
- Please, oh my god.
- [Kelly] Just let me do the harmonies.